With new, exciting
mobile devices coming out
every day with new screen
sizes and resolutions,
it can be difficult making
sure your images look
best on every new device
that hits the stores.
Hi.
I'm Tenghui from the
Android UI Tokyo team,
and I'm here to help you make
your graphics look their best
by telling you all the new
vector graphics support
we have added in
Android 5.0, Lollipop.
So what are vector graphics, and
why would you want to use them?
A normal bitmap represent images
as a set of pixels in a grid.
But with vector graphics,
you can represent an image
by describing the
object geometrically.
This means you can
describe an image
as a set of points,
lines, and curves,
along with all the
associated color information.
So how does this help you?
The major advantage for vector
graphics is image scalability.
Take a look at
this bitmap images.
It looks fine on a low-res
screen with a size of 100x100.
But if you would put it
on the high-res screen
with a size of 400x400--
while we can scaled it out,
you can see how it
ends up looking blurry.
So what many
developers end up doing
is creating multiple
versions of each image
for different
display resolutions.
This means more time
to create extra access,
and more space taken up by
the APK and on the device.
But with vector images, you only
need to create an image once,
as an XML file.
And it can scale beautifully
for all different DPIs
for different devices.
This not only save space, but
also simplify maintainance.
You can also use vector
images for animation.
Instead of having
multiple series
of images for all
different DPIs,
now all you need is
just several XML files.
Prior to the Lollipop
release, if you ever
wanted to draw anything
using vector representation,
you had to manually do it
all in Java code, which
was cumbersome.
In Lollipop, we
have two new classes
to support vector graphics
as our drawable resources.
VectorDrawable, and
AnimatedVectorDrawable.
VectorDrawable defines a
static drawable object,
while AnimatedVectorDrawable
can add animations
to the properties
of VectorDrawable.
They are both
subclasses of Drawable,
and they are both
represented by XML files.
Let's take a look
at the XML structure
of the VectorDrawable.
Similar to the XVG format,
each VectorDrawable
can be represented
as a tree hierarchy.
Geometry is defined
in a path text, which
are all the leaves of this tree.
All the path descriptions
and joint attributes
are inside this tech.
All path will be joined
in the same order
as they appear in the XML file.
Transformations are defined
in a group tag which
are the internal
nodes of the tree.
Know that for each path
object, its transformation
is inherited from all
its ancestor groups'
transformation, applied
in the order from the top
to the bottom.
Here's how it looks
like in the XML file.
You can clearly see
the tree structure
with those highlighted texts.
Feel free to see more details
in the link, as shown below.
Now let's switch to the
AnimatedVectorDrawable.
First, here is the
diagram of its structure.
On the top, the
AnimatedVectorDrawable's XML
is essentially a
little bit of glue
which connects the
VectorDrawable's XML,
on the bottom left, with
the object animator's XML
files over there on
the bottom right,
which describe the
animations for the properties
of a VectorDrawable.
To actually glue
those two things up,
AnimatedVectorDrawable
uses names
to find a target object inside
the VectorDrawable, like the G1
here.
Notice that the target
object to be animated
can be either a group,
a path, or a [INAUDIBLE]
and they must be uniquely named.
Then, we can apply the
specified object animator,
like the a.xml in this
example to the target
object we just find by name.
Inside the object
animator, we need
to specify the property
name to animate,
like the rotation
in this example,
and the values for animation.
Now, let's take a
look at an example
of an AnimatedVectorDrawable.
First, before adding
the animations,
the image on the left shows
how the static VectorDrawable
looks, and its XML code
is on the right hand side.
If we add an animation of the
group's rotation property,
like this, then we can get the
rotation animations, like this.
If we add animation to the
path's color attributes,
like this, then we
can change the color
of the sun from orange
to red, like this.
Moreover, if we animate
a path data attributes,
like this, notice the value time
now is set to the path time.
Then, we can change
the shape of the sun
as a path morphing in
this cute animation.
Now let's talk about some of
the trade offs and performance
aspects of these new classes.
VectorDrawable has
performance implications.
With that in mind, my
suggestions are first,
simplify the vector
representation of an object.
For example, avoid using
many opt-to commands
in the path data.
Second, limit image size
of your VectorDrawable.
Because these
Drawables are first
drawn into bitmaps then uploaded
to the texture on the GPU,
larger bitmaps means more
memory and more time to upload.
Practically, I would
recommend using VectorDrawable
for icons and buttons
with reasonable sizes.
For example, less
than 200x200 DP.
Third, don't update
the attributes
of the VectorDrawable
unless necessary.
When there's no changes to the
attributes like width, height,
or alpha, our framework will
be able to keep a cached bitmap
without redrawing the path or
reuploading texture to the GPU.
For AnimatedVectorDrawable,
caching won't help here.
So keep your animations
short and sweet.
Additionally, animating
the path data attributes
or the [INAUDIBLE]
path attributes
are heavy operations.
Try to see if you can
use transformation only
for your animation to avoid
those heavy operations.
One last question
you might have is,
how do I create an XML file
for the VectorDrawable?
Our tool team is hard at
work on building new tools
to help you generate
these XML files.
In the meantime, it's actually
possible to create them
by hand with just a little work.
First, you can use
any joint program
that can export SVG
to create your images.
Then, with a little
cutting and pasting,
you can get the contents
into your XML files.
The VectorDrawable and
AnimatedVectorDrawables
are awesome classes
that can help
you to build a better-looking,
smaller app in an easier way.
Please follow these
links for more details
on how to use them.
Thank you.